(soft ambient music)
- [Narrator] As a global health
emergency is taking hold,
America is moving forward
with its crucial once-a-decade census.
In March, the Census Bureau
said an employee tested positive
for the new coronavirus.
The worker didn't have
contact with the public,
but the incident is
reinforcing the bureau's need
to collect information over the internet.
This isn't the bureau's only challenge
as it collects surveys.
The 2020 census has been on
the Government Accountability
Office's watch list
for three years.
Those concerns, combined with
pandemic-driven impediments,
could make 2020's count
more difficult to execute,
but the count must move forward
because it is a foundational
part of American governance.
- The census is very important
because it is the foundation
of how political power
is distributed in this country.
And so, it's important to be counted,
and it's not just that people be included
but be included where they reside
so that political power can
be equitably distributed
or accurately distributed.
- [Narrator] Here's how the new dynamics
are reshaping 2020's count.
This year, most households
received a letter
rather than a complete
census form in the mail.
- This is the first census
in which there'll be
a widespread option to
respond over the internet.
- [Narrator] That's because the census
wanted to move toward online response.
In light of the new coronavirus,
the bureau's reemphasizing
the need to respond online
or by phone or by mail
without having to meet a census-taker.
This is the safest way
to answer the census,
and that could prove crucial
as the country hunkers down
to increase social distance
and limit the spread of the virus.
Online response will limit the amount
of in-person enumeration
needed to count everyone,
which relates to another major challenge
facing 2020's census: staffing.
Staffing has been an
ongoing area of concern
at the Census Bureau.
That problem becomes most
visible at the local level.
- One of the things that's very important
is to look at the census down
at almost a granular level,
a very local level.
That's what's gonna make
or break the census.
- [Narrator] Only about
two-thirds of the country
responded to the initial
prompt for the 2010 census,
and those numbers vary at the local level.
For example, about 74% of Minnesotans
responded to the census's first request,
but some counties in the state
had response rates below 40%.
Lower response rates mean
that the Census Bureau
needs to send temporary
workers to knock on doors
and request responses in person.
But the need to increase social distance
will make it harder to
send field workers out
to track hard-to-reach populations
and others who don't respond.
For months, the Census Bureau struggled
to recruit enough temporary workers.
The GAO issued this chart in February
to show how far behind
the bureau had fallen.
The Census Bureau disputed those findings,
saying that they effectively
met their staffing goals,
but the bureau will
still have to deal with
falling response rates.
That's because Americans in general
have become less likely to answer surveys.
- Each census that I've
been involved with,
the bureau assumes a
lower mail response rate
than they received in
the preceding census,
in part because of just the
complexity of counting people
in various living arrangements,
but in part because of reduction in trust.
- [Narrator] Which brings us
to a third major challenge
facing 2020's census: trust.
In 2019, the Republican National Committee
sent a 2020 Congressional District Census
to a number of households.
It was not an official census.
The document asks about
political preferences
and preferred news sources,
none of which are asked
on the official census.
The questionnaire was also much longer
than the official census
and asked respondents
to donate money to process the document.
As recently as March, the Trump campaign
promoted the misleading
prompt on Facebook.
Facebook later removed the ads,
citing the company's
census interference policy.
But experts say that the lingering effects
of confusing documents like this
could further depress
response rates in the country.
Census forms started arriving
in mailboxes in mid-March.
The bureau must report results to Congress
no later than December of 2020.
Some response timetables
could be shaken up
as the bureau monitors the situation
and takes new guidance from
public health authorities.
(soft ambient music)